[Musik]
ige
Leute ein spontanes Konzert der Punkband
feine Sahne Fischfilet im Juni 11 Tage
nach dem Wahlsieg der AFD in Sonneberg
die Musiker wollen zeigen dass hier
nicht alle rechts sind der Hilferuf an
die Band kam direkt aus der Region
wir fühlen uns hilflos wir haben das
Gefühl wie scheiße die AFD Scheiße
wechseln zu ihren Kopf und es wäre
einfach toll wenn ihr bei uns spielt und
dann saßen wir einfach zusammen weil wir
gerade sowieso auf Tour sind und haben
gesagt boah
wir können natürlich nicht immer die
ganze Zeit Feuerwehr spielen ja weil es
passiert natürlich ja ganz oft
irgendwelche scheiße aber die Leute
fühlen wir halt hier sehr ja wir kommen
auch aus Mecklenburg-Vorpommern wir
wissen wie es ist wenn man in der
Provinz lebt
positioniert sich seit Jahren klar gegen
rechts
hier sind alle geschockt über den
Wahlerfolg der AFD auch der Barbetreiber
ich sage nicht dass alle AFD Wähler
Nazis sind aber ich sag ganz klar jeder
hat davon Nazis gewählt jeder der die
AFD gewählt hat hat Nazis gewählt und
ich glaube auch dass es den Menschen
bewusst war
aber anscheinend egal
weltspielzeug statt Sonneberg
früher mal der ganze Stolz Teddys werden
noch heute mitten in der Stadt
produziert
freut mich dass es sowas noch gibt und
dass das mir der Hände was was wir mit
der Hände was schaffen können
die Teddy Manufaktur gibt es seit fast
100 Jahren geführt in fünfter Generation
von Sina Martin alles ist feinster
Handarbeit der Wahlsieg der AFD ein eher
unschönes Thema
jede wird seine Gründe haben warum wählt
na ich denke es kann glaube ich keine
Vorhersagen wieder innen noch außen wie
das jetzt weitergeht bei uns und man
muss vielleicht auch der Sache gar nicht
so eine große Welle drum machen
Robert Sesselmann macht aber eine große
Welle sein erster Auftritt als Landrat
im Kreistag Interviews gibt er keiner
uns auch nicht im Kreis Sonneberg haben
knapp 53% ihn ins Amt gewählt der erste
Landtag des rechtsextremen
Landesverbandes der AFD
Hausverbot für Neonazis das gilt auch
für den neuen Landrat in der
Goetheschule in Lauscha Handwerk und
Künste arbeiten hier Tür an Tür das ist
wie so ein kleines Wohnzimmer hier für
mich wir haben hier verschiedene Räume
in dem wir verschiedene Sachen machen
können das Künstler Kollektiv
Goetheschule folgt dem bauhauskonzept
und bringt buntes Leben ins 35 km
entfernte Lauscher
[Musik]
auch internationale Gäste kommen in das
ehemalige Schulgebäude Tino Köhler Terz
und seine 30 Mitstreiter hat die näher
rückende afd-realität aufgeschrieben
Angst
haben wir keine aber Respekt
heute 1933
und es ist kein Problem
das muss man ganz deutlich sagen und wer
heute schreit das in die Thüringer wird
morgen AFD Landräte haben egal wo
tief im Osten oder tief im Westen
[Musik]
lasst euch nicht verführen
es gibt keine Wiederkehr
der Tag steht in den Türen Probe für
einen Bertolt brecht-abend von Steffen
Mensching im Theater Rudolstadt eine
poetische Nummern Revue mit Clowns und
Musikern bei der Verführung ist
Wichtigste dass wir als Regisseur
inszeniert er bewusst anspielungsreich
um auch die aktuelle Situation in
Thüringen zu spiegeln
eine traurige Tradition das war auch das
erste
Bundesland sozusagen in der in der
Weimarer Republik wo die Nazis in den
Parlamenten saßen und mitbestimmt haben
das ist ein Beginn deswegen hat es ja
die AFD so abgefeiert auch diesen ersten
Landratsposten man erwartet sich da mehr
und die traurige Wahrheit ist man kann
sich da auch mehr erwarten wenn die
Zahlen so weitergehen wie bisher als
Intendant ist er pessimistisch rechnet
fest damit dass viele Kunstschaffende
und intellektuelle Thüringen schon bald
verlassen die werden jetzt nicht gleich
alle nach
Norwegen oder sonst wo er versuchen zu
fliehen das nicht aber die werden sich
in die urbanen Zentren begeben wo
einfach eine größere Liberalität und
eine größere Lässigkeit und eine größere
Toleranz existiert
Flüchtlinge in Sonneberg ein wichtiger
Anlaufpunkt die Kleiderkammer
organisiert vom Verein Brücken bauen
Petra Gundermann managed hier alles in
Räumen einer ehemaligen Schule das
Hausrecht hat hier der Landrat jetzt von
der AFD wenn der das anordnet müsste der
Verein seiner Aktivität im Gebäude
einstellen im Landkreis leben knapp
1.000 geflüchtete aus der Ukraine und
genauso viele Asylbewerber
Petra Gundermann sagt die Migranten
haben Angst
meine Migranten will ich mal sagen ich
bin ja mit vielen schon jahrelang
befreundet arabisch und afghanisch und
so weiter die haben schon Angst also sie
haben zu mir gesagt jetzt ist ein
Landrat von der AFD müssen jetzt alle
raus aus Deutschland habe ich gesagt ihr
braucht keine Angst zu haben die Gesetze
kann er auch nicht ändern wenn es so ist
und ihr habt Aufenthalt dann ist es so
ne aber die Angst ist schon da unter den
Leuten
Sonneberg Sommer 2023 die AFD ist laut
Verfassungsschutz gesichert rechtsextrem
AFD Landeschef Björn höcke am vorderster
Front
es gibt in Thüringen keine Trennlinie
zwischen der AFD und der klassischen
neonazis-szene sagt Felix Steiner mobile
Beratungen Thüringen Moped Feierabend in
Sonneberg seltsam beengt zwischen Frust
und Gleichgültigkeit ob der es bei der
AFD oder bei der CDU oder bei der SPD
Hauptsache macht seine Arbeit gut ne die
Zukunft
macht seine Arbeit ich mache nichts mehr
ich will nicht mehr ich mache nichts
mehr ich habe mein
Hobby mein Garten und will von Politik
nichts mehr wissen es wird nichts in der
Richtung passieren dass es den Leuten
wieder besser geht auch wenn ein Landrat
von der AFD
ist zum Konzert der fünf Musiker sind
850 Zuschauer gekommen ein Abend mit
wechselndem Publikum und klaren
Statements
der oft gerne angesprochen wird der hat
hier gar keinen gar keinen Nährboden
Sonneberg ist keine Stadt der ist
schlecht geht niemand der hier lebt
dem muss es schlecht gehen wir sind eine
Stadt wo Potenzial ist das ist keine
Stadt in der man
ärmlich vor sich hinlebt sag ich mal wie
in den ganz ländlichen Regionen in
Brandenburg wo man einfach keine Chance
hat einen Job zu bekommen hier kann man
einen Job bekommen wenn man möchte doch
all das kann nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen die AFD ist im Aufwind
mit ihrem Kulturkampf und setzt im Osten
auf das kommende Jahr
2024 sind gleich drei Landtagswahlen in
Thüringen Sachsen und in Brandenburg
[Applaus]